President Biden's managed to ruin
Thanksgiving again no he's not inviting
Hunter to your family gathering this
year and the big guy himself will be
kicking back in Nantucket for the
holiday it's because the price of your
Feast is going to cost you an arm and a
turkey leg the average cost of a
Thanksgiving dinner is up 20 percent
this year but don't worry
Brian can afford it Biden's goons at the
USDA are blaming Russia for the rising
costs and if that's not bad enough there
could be a crippling rail strike in
December it could literally slam the
brakes on the economy and cost 2 billion
per day but wait I remember Biden
bragging about how this wasn't a problem
anymore
this agreement is a big win for America
together we reached an agreement you
reached an agreement that will keep our
critical rail system working and avoid
disruptions of our economy and this is a
win for tens of thousands of rail
workers and for their dignity the White
House trying to spin their failure to
avert the strike by pointing out how
they kicked the can down the road
what we're saying is that it averted a a
horrible uh downturn in our economy by
that that tentative agreement it was a
big deal what it could have done to our
economy uh would have been devastating
it was an important it was an important
the tentative agreement was indeed
important again because it stopped uh
it's it stopped a a horrible
um uh potential downturn again to our
economy
do you want to comment on that
explanation
it's just good enough just
not just in hold and that and that
unfortunate and we got to move on
instead of trying to say like how great
it was I mean it was a political
Band-Aid that got them through the
midterms that gave them a Rose Garden
event so that they could go out and say
oh everybody's fine thank God Joe
Biden's here thank god he's a deal maker
thank goodness he has Pete bootage and
Marty Walsh on his cabinet crisis
averted just enough to get through the
midterms similar similarly the student
loan crisis right he says I'm going to
give everyone the student loan thing and
then it gets through the midterms and
like actually no it's not constitutional
but sorry about that they tried to do it
with the Saudis on the loan deal right
they try to ask the Saudis to not
um well to increase their production
Saudi said no they tried to do that we
know that they try to do it and said can
you just wait until after the election
well now it's after the election and I I
it'll be interesting to see how
Republicans and Democrats both play this
right because in the political
realignment we're living in the both
parties are trying to go after the
working class
and so the rail Strikers they're close
on a deal they're saying they want to
have a better quality of life they want
more time with their family yes it looks
like they're getting a 24 raise in the
deal they say that's Pennies on the
dollar compared to the amount of time
that they spend so where is everybody
going to come down on this I think that
part's pretty interesting to see but
just be aware of the political Band-Aids
oh and there's another one by the way
now if you have a student loan you don't
have to pay your student loan through
probably of August of 2023 but if you
took out a loan for an F-150 so you
could run your business you're gonna
have to make your payment sorry people
who need a loan for the Thanksgiving
dinner it's up 20 percent remember when
they had that little July 4th picture
where they were like we saved you three
cents this year are we gonna see that
for Thanksgiving I'm not sure but there
was a story out there trying to validate
it that people are buying big chickens
instead of big turkeys because chickens
are so you know it's it's less money uh
so we'll see where that stands but
inflation is just interesting I did not
know it would end up back at Vladimir
Putin's lab but we're exactly with
Vladimir Putin I forgot about that uh
and Nordstrom one in Nordstrom too but
there's a couple of things going on the
student loan forgiveness this is ongoing
how can he do that just kicks it down
for six more months which is great but
if you took out a loan now and you have
a freshman in college now you're not
eligible for it if you graduate now you
don't have to pay for it I just never I
I've never seen anything quite like this
and and this whole thing with uh
inflation and uh and uh the the turkey
dinner I think it's it's basically
emblematic of what's been going on the
President says seven percent is not a
big deal because they didn't go up to
eight percent but we're all paying more
for everything and it doesn't seem to
matter if this was the week before the
midterms I would say this is a big deal
but after the midterms when you see just
a slight wind for Republicans I don't
know what resonates and you know when
you go out to dinner Harold it's the
food does cost a lot but it's the
alcohol bill that really gets you and
that's not a personal statement so I
think I think this whole notion Brian
you rate I think you made the most
important Point as we think about
inflation and bite inflation no don't I
think Dana framed us all the right way
to have her reaction her reaction about
the press secretary I thought was right
she should just move on from it we
thought we had a deal we don't have a
deal at least we have some framework and
we hope we can get something here but
this is this for whatever reason it has
not resonated politically with the
country and it is not moving resonates
but it doesn't move them to vote for the
other part they've not assigned Blame A
sufficient blame to Democrats on this
and I've struggled with trying to figure
this out too uh part of me thinks that
it's because a couple things one
um people are people still have some
Reserve cash from from whatever that
time may be could have been some of the
the stimulus that took place back in 20
and 21
or two people have decided to prioritize
things differently and they're not
they're not finding themselves having to
sacrifice in their lives whatever it is
it's a new normal as it relates to our
economy because if we are in a recession
we've never seen a recession where
you're producing jobs that we're
producing where you have consumer
sentiment elevated not as high as it was
and people still spending money so
something is happening in our economy
and something's happening in our society
that defies sort of the normal way we
look at the economy and we look at
supply and demand finally I think that
that if these numbers persist and where
I do think it's fair to blame Putin or
to involve him in the conversation is
that gas prices and energy prices are
going to go up continue to go up it's
going to go up in Europe which will
impact us as well if I were Republicans
where I'd be trying to get something to
resonate if I were Democrats trying to
blunt it domestic energy production I
don't know it's good for him to be at
the border with a million barrels a day
right but that's all all I would be
talking about because if indeed
Democrats are right I don't want to give
the Republicans about the Playbook they
should be playing but if if Democrats
are saying Putin is the reason that
prices are up then if I were McCarthy
and Republicans I'd be saying we need to
increase domestic energy production it's
good to be at the border but why not
address the issue that Democrats agree
is the issue and frankly Europeans know
is the issue and Americans we're going
to unfortunately confront as natural gas
prices continue to rise throughout the
winter and I pray and hope that we have
an answer to not only the the long term
but the immediate term of trying to help
families pay for their energy bills
Harold's making some sense he is making
some sense you know Joe Biden came in I
always go back to this he came in the
Trojan Horse He was the moderate but he
wasn't the moderate and even today one
of the members of the squad wants him to
run for president again uh and you know
you could say that they may not yet have
assign blame but what Joe Biden is going
to do for the next two years is blame
the Republicans blaming that Republicans
for the student loan thing when the
question is whether or not it's even
legal and you know he's blaming Putin
for something as you say very very
correctly that we can contain we can
take care of our own domestic energy
production all right so who's to blame
bidens to blame for the fact that we
went from energy efficient to uh not
having any difference energy independent
to not having any now and begging to the
Saudis and then the Venezuelans and
everyone else to give us oil so I mean
it is devastating this rail thing is
devastating it's a trojan horse again I
came out and I really took care of this
possible rail strike that's going to
cost us two billion dollars a day if it
doesn't for a month yeah and and I I did
I did my uh Victory lap but it really
wasn't well and it didn't didn't work
and you really didn't uh close the whole
thing as it relates to the loans and you
you really didn't uh you know you
haven't done anything for domestic
energy production and so stop blaming
other people you've been lying since you
were in the Trojan Horse but In fairness
if everybody believed your points you
would have had a better night last
Tuesday two weeks ago I'm only saying I
try to call balls and Strikes and at the
end of the day we all have to take
lessons from this election you know it
would have been great and we've got a
republican plan in Europe and we got we
could have built it by now it's been a
year and a half we could have had uh for
the last nine months we could have
natural gas going right to Europe we
could have replaced the Russians already
and we would have been paid for our
natural gas production but the president
doesn't want to do it doesn't want to
drill in federal land he doesn't want to
do anything and evidently the country
doesn't want that doesn't want what
you're saying you're assuming that that
one issue is what made the Democrats not
lose as big as people said they would
lose why are you assuming it that it's
that one issue well the only data point
we really have is an election that took
place two weeks ago so you can jump you
can jump on me but the bottom line is
the other night was an underwhelming
night for Republicans yeah but we so won
the house so let's not forget that I
mean I don't agree with you are you
saying Democrats rejected the idea of
domestic energy production based on that
election you can't say that I didn't I
I'm agreeing with you but I'm saying you
didn't lay out a set of answers I don't
think Republicans laid out a sufficient
and convincing and persuasive set of
answers that made the American people
believe that they should be entrusted to
do that we call balls and Strikes too
Harold let's get that straight our
Strike Zone's a little wider but they do
still call absolutely strikes hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else